what's a physiological sayigh uh so
that's um just a breathing technique so
you um you take a a large in breath and
then just when you feel like your lungs
are full you take in another small
breath and then you do a long sort of
vigorous out breath
so so it's allowing the out breath to be
longer than the in breath um and I I
talk about lots of it's just one of the
different ways to kind of do slow
breathing techniques um um but they're
all in the book what do they do like
what's the the theory behind it so the
idea is you're not only you kind of
slowing your heart rate down but when
you take that extra in breath that
you're opening up the little sacks and
your lungs a little bit wider so you're
actually getting rid of carbon carbon
dioxide more efficiently than you would
be um so it helps you to sort of calm
the system and honestly it you know
those really small things no one can
even see you're doing it but it makes it
enough of a
difference